oui
[Musique]
est venu sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour une émission
entièrement consacrée au philosophe
michel onfray bonjour michel onfray
on va passer presque une heure ensemble
vous publiez la nef des fous ces
sous-titrés des nouvelles du bas-empire
chez bouquins chez bouquins également
paraît vie philosophique c'est la
reddition en un seul et gros volume de
tous vos livres sur nietzsche camus des
victor o charlotte corday ou freud et
puis il ya le numéro 4 de votre revue
front populaire qui paraissent sur le
thème de l'immigration avec la
participation de pascal bruckner chantal
delsol j'accepte pierre-yves michou
mathieu nos côtés dans votre éditorial
vous parler également de civilisation et
de décadence
à quoi reconnaît-on le naufrage d'une
civilisation michel onfray d'après vous
et à très joli texte de segalen qui
s'appelle les immémoriaux qui raconte
comment omar qu'ils ont peut voir
s'effondrer une civilisation c'est plus
facile que de penser à la chute de rome
il ya eu tellement d'hypothèses sur la
chute de rome et segalen nous lie très
précisément dès qu'on a cessé d'avoir la
mémoire des ancêtres
dès qu'on ne sait plus raconter des
généalogies dès qu'on ait perdu sur ce
qui nous a fait constituer alors la
place est faite pour ceux qui arriveront
par la suite c'est à dire que par
exemple quand les jésuites arrive ne
détruisent pas la civilisation maori
mais parce que la civilisation mabri
s'est détruite elle même les jésuites
peuvent arriver nous dit segalen et je
pense effectivement que nous n'avons
plus ce souci de l'histoire nous n'avons
plus ce souci du passé nous détestons ne
les testons le passé on réécrit les
classiques on n'enseigne plus un certain
nombre de choses on estime que tout ça
est has been que c'est du passé que on
ne peut plus lire par exemple madame
bovary intégralement parce que c'est
trop long et qu'il faut faire des just
qu'ensuite il ya des auteurs dont il
faut pas parler parce qu'ils sont
politiquement incorrect donc je pense à
ce moment là effectivement que penser de
haine que nous avons dû passer dans ce
présent absolument impossible est dans
la configuration d'un avenir dont on ne
sait à quoi il va ressembler on est dans
la situation effectivement 2
dans une civilisation wii qui s'effondre
et vous faites vous dit vous sous titrer
votre autre livre nouvelles du
bas-empire taux bas' empire romain que
vous faites allusion bien entendu mais
est ce qu'on est sûr que est ce que vous
êtes sûr que l' empire romain s'est bien
effondré à la fin du bas-empire est-ce
qu'il ne s'est pas renouvelé au fond
est-ce qu'il n'a pas perduré à la fois
avec le saint-empire romain d'orient à
constantinople d'abord puis avec
l'empiré chrétien tout simplement qui
lui a succédé avec la même capitale en
plus rome
ah oui mais je n'ai jamais pensé qu'une
civilisation quand elle s'effondre et
disparaissez comme par enchantement en
laissant plus rien derrière elle il ya
un moment de tuilage et le bas empire
est un moment de tuilage c'est à dire
qu'on a un empire pas forcément romain
je dirais non plutôt gréco latins et
puis ensuite on a un empire judéo
chrétien est il comme il ya eu un
tuilage justement le moment de cette
huile âge c'est le moment du bas-empire
nous vivons un moment de tuilage avec
une autre civilisation qui advient et
sept autres civilisations qui advient
bien sûr qu'elle va procéder du
judéo-christianisme donc on va on va
voir on voit déjà d'ailleurs un peu
comment ça fonctionne on va garder un
certain nombre de schémas je pense que
tout ce qui est pêché originel punition
confession contrition toutes ces choses
là fonctionne très bien aujourd'hui tout
ce qui est très chrétien les processus
et blé les processus mais procédure
d'aveu je dirais comme pour pour
utiliser le vocabulaire du michel
foucault c'est tout ce qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui vous n'avez vous n'avez pas
bien fait dans le passé vous avez été
des colons vous avez été des vichystes
vous avez été des nazis vous allaitez
des collaborateurs etc etc et donc
demandé pardon
et puis effacé vous m'aider à genoux en
tant prié et peut-être qu'on pourra vous
pardonner donc on gardera effectivement
ce schéma de la résipiscence et puis on
ira vers une civilisation qui me semble
être celle du transhumanisme
c'est-à-dire de l'artificialité
l'artificialisation totale de ce qui est
ou ce qui est nature aujourd'hui et
détruits
on a la haine de la nature même si on
s'entasse une espèce de nature
d'écologie et quelques unes en nature de
durban en fait et pas du tout de roue
on est dans cette veine de la nature
parce qu'il faut tout artificialisés ya
pas de garçon n'est pas de filles à
padum n'y a pas de femmes
il ya ce qu'on veut il ya le projet n'y
a pas d'enfant il n'ya pas d'adolescent
n'ya pas d'adultes jeunes filles comme
d'attenberg peut être une adulte mais en
même temps un enfant dans le ventre de
sa mère peut être un mort et un cadavres
parce que si on en a plus le projet bien
ce moment là on peut trouver cet enfant
neuf mois quelques jours avant qu'il ne
naisse parce que ça devient quelque
chose qui est légalement consentis donc
effectivement cette artificialisation du
tout elle procède d'une partie aussi de
la biotechnologie qui nous a emballés
notre civilisation à partir de
l'invention du moteur et d'électricité
partir du 19ème siècle celui qui disait
exactement la même chose que vous mais
ya trente ans c'était jacques attali
dans l'ordre cannibale et qui disait lui
aussi
on va vers une vérification du monde
tout sera marchandises est et on est et
ce qui adviendra c'est aussi la une
civilisation transhumanistes
ça m'étonne que vous pensiez la même
chose que jacques attali et ça doit vous
étonnez vous aussi peut-être d'ailleurs
mais ça m'étonne pas du tout parce que
lui le pense en pensant que c'est
formidable moi je n'agis non catastrophe
il le dénonce à tous et il a écrit mais
il écrit un livre qui s'appelle demain
qui gouvernera le monde qui s'inscrit
tout à fait dans cette logique là nous
disons que c'est de toute façon quelque
chose qui est écrit que le monde sera
gouverner un jour et le transhumanisme
procède de cette planétarisation du
monde et je vous assure que je ne pense
pas comme lui sur ce sujet là je suis
dit quand je dis que le soleil se lève
le matin qu'il le dit aussi
on va pas commencer à dire que matt
allié à tort parce que il ne dit que des
sottises et que donc le soleil ne se
lève jamais le matin qui se lève plus
tôt le soir donc attali travaille à ce
projet et moi je travaille à ne pas
arrêter ce projet pourra l'arrêter mais
a simplement dire ce qu'il est et à
faire savoir que il me parlait était
stable mais je vous garantis qui le
dénonce et que même dans qui demain qui
gouvernera le monde mais c'est pas le
sujet peu importe dans dans la nef des
fous
donc votre je suis pas sûr si je puis me
permettre de me permettre de vous
reprendre suis pas sûr que ce ne soit
pas le sujet c'est même très exactement
de sujets je pense qu'elle est la
civilisation judéo chrétienne qui
disparaît ne sera peut-être remplacé par
une civilisation que je dirais locales
qui pourraient être musulmane en temps
mais ça n'empêchera pas que de toute
façon il y aura un moment donné une
civilisation qu'israël global total
définitive et qui sera pour le coup
planétaire donc je pense que le le mixte
d'orwell 1984 deux axes les meilleurs
des mondes nous montre à peu près ce
vers quoi nous allons
moi j'estime qu'effectivement c'est une
catastrophe attali estime qu'au
contraire il faut appuyer à fond sur
l'accélérateur et que tout ça est
formidable et que plus vite on arrivera
à ça mieux ce sera moi je pense que
accélérer quand on est au bord d'une
falaise c'est pas forcément la meilleure
chose qu'on est à faire dans la nef des
fous vous déployez une verve satirique
assez drôle j'ai j'ai beaucoup ri même
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec vous à
mon avis on ne peut en rien parce que
les exemples sont fort bien choisi et
c'est bien écrit mais vous y dénoncer
une société entièrement gagné par
l'islamo gauchisme
or on a entendu les accusations d' islam
beauxis proférées par jean michel
blanquer puis prof
frédéric vidal on les a accusés de
relayer des fantasmes d'extrême droite
de ne pas savoir du tout de quoi il
parlait
c'était un mauvais procès qu'on leur
faisait j'imagine que vous étiez de leur
côté quand vous avez entendu ça vous
savez négationnisme consiste à dire que
le réel n'a pas eu lieu voir que leur
elle n'a pas lieu il n'y a pas eu de
chambres à gaz
voilà il n'ya pas d'islam au gauchisme
jadis déjà n'y avait pas de théorie du
genre donc à faire était réglé circulez
on va pas discuter avec vous puisque
vous fantasmez sur une réalité qui
n'existe pas donc il ya des gens qui
effectivement croit ce qu'il voit je
pense que c'est mon cas et puis d'autres
qui voient ce qu'il croit et c'est le
cas d'un certain nombre de gens qui
estime qu' ils ont décidé que ça
n'existe pas donc ça n'existe pas or
c'est un concept quand ces gens-là nous
disent le cnrs a décidé que ça n'était
pas un concept scientifique j'adore le
concept scientifique
tous ces gens qui parlent de fachosphère
qui parle d' extrême droite à tout bout
de champ qui estime qu' cd&v gist des
pétainistes moi par exemple quand j'ai
créé cette revue avec stéphane simon
bernard henri lévy et quelques autres
jean françois kahn ou jacques julliard
par exemple ont estimé que j'étais
doriot ça c'est extrêmement scientifique
d'imaginer qu'une revue qui n'était pas
encore écrite en était en train de
travailler à sa construction elle puisse
être comparée aux thèses fasciste de
doriot qui a porté l'uniforme des nazis
sur le front russe dire ce sont ces gens
là ce sont les mêmes qui nous disent
qu'ils aient pas d'islam au gauchisme
qui nous disent que tout ça n'est pas
très scientifique et que la
scientificité
ça permettrait de parler de fachosphère
par exemple ou de traiter de pétainiste
ou de deux types d'extrême droite
quiconque ne passerait pas comme eux
donc ça fait bien longtemps que j'ai
plus j'ai plus de soucis de ce que dit
ces gens là je vois le réel j'estime
mais effectivement il est aujourd'hui
une espèce de complaisance à l'endroit
de l'islam qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
penser l'islam autrement qu'en termes de
dévotion vous êtes compte pas faire
d'histoires on ne peut pas renvoyer au
texte on peut pas renvoyer au a dit on
ne peut pas renvoyer à la biographie du
prophète parce que nous on est taxé de
l'islamophobie et l'islamophobie c'est
ce qu'ils mangent l'un des péchés
véniels mais quasi mortel dans cette
société il ya également les études de
genre qui ont été épinglés à la fois par
jean-michel bancaire et par frédéric
vidal et ils ne sont pas les seuls et
par vous puisque d'une certaine manière
en faisant indirectement on voit bien
que à quel point ça vous agace
qu'est ce que vous en tout cas quand on
veut quand on lit la nef des fous
l'impression que ça a fait des ravages
dans la société française
qu'est ce que vous reprochez aux études
de genre et est ce que vous en avez pas
à peu rajouté est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que vraiment à ce point ça
a gagné les esprits et protège le
principe de ce livre c'est c'est je
trouve à bord une sottise par jour donc
je démarre au 1er janvier et je termine
au 31 décembre est parfois j'en trouve
beaucoup plus qu'une par jour
et donc c'est à partir de cas concrets
que je pense le real tu es petit lait
alors on peut vaguement disserter sur la
théorie du genre en faisant comme najat
vallaud-belkacem disant que ça n'existe
pas mais qu'il n'y ait que des études
chacun aura compris que la théorie du
genre et les études de genre c'est pas
exactement la même chose évidemment que
c'est la même chose
enfin je pars du réel et j'essaie de
pâtes en penser le réel parce que vous
avez vu c'est sous forme d'apport par
d'aphorismes c'est un court texte
la plupart du temps mais de voir ce que
ces choses là disent de nous par exemple
est une petite fille de 8 ans qui
intervient cortenaise parlement espagnol
ou devant les députés nous dit ça fait
quatre ans que j'ai envie de changer de
sexe je me dis qu'une petite fille de 8
ans qui a envie depuis quatre ans c'est
à dire depuis l'âge de 4 ans but depuis
quatre ans de durée également qui a
envie de changer de sexe avec
l'assentiment de ses parents c'est que
quelque chose ne va pas bien
jadis dans les civilisations dans les
cités on a toujours eu dans les cités je
peux pas les citer au sens contemporain
lecteurs je pense aux cités grecques ou
ou aux villes on avait toujours un
moment d'initiation d'un individu c'est
à dire qu'on estimait que lé un enfant
n'était pas fait pour rester un enfant
que du jour au lendemain il devenait
adulte par un rite initiatique
l'adolescence est tardif on a inventé
l'adolescence mais à un moment donné où
quand on a les cantons quitté l'école et
qu'on travaille on était un adulte
exactement comme quand gauguin se
retrouve aux marquises d'une jeune fille
une petite fille eh bien elle n'a pas
ses règles et puis le jour où elle a ses
règles elle est une femme
et si elle a ses règles à 12 ans ou 13
ans c'est une femme dont il ya eu des
moments où effectivement estimé qu' un
enfant n'était pas fait pour rester un
enfant mais pour devenir un adulte et
ont initié l'enfant pour qu'il devienne
un adulte c'est à dire que les parents
les éducateurs travailler à la
construction de l'identité d'un être il
ne travaillait pas à la destruction de
l'identité qu'ils ne travaillaient pas
au doute sur l'identité c'est à dire que
j'ai vu l'autre jour sur la chaîne
parlementaire c'est-à-dire une chaîne
d'état qui fonctionne avec de l'argent
public alors l'impôt du contribuable un
reportage qui nous montrait qu'un
instituteur voulons c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui n'était pas attachée à des
classes mais qui allait de classe en
classe
histoire de bien faire des ravages un
peu partout allez dans la classe et une
dizaine en faire un groupe de garçons
puis un groupe de filles et puis quand
il a vu les gars ont commencé par
instiller le doute dans la tête des
garçons
bon tout le monde a l'impression que
vous êtes des garçons ici un êtes bien
sûr que vous êtes des garçons et qu'est
ce qui fait que vous n'êtes pas des
filles
est-ce que parmi vous quelqu'un n'aurait
pas déjà envie d'être une fille et ses
états même discours inversée avec les
jeunes filles à qui on dit vous ne vous
êtes des petites filles vous pensez vous
êtes des petites filles mais pourquoi
parce qu'on vous le dit vous n'auriez
pas envie d'être un garçon ça ne vous
dirai rien de temps en temps de changer
le sexe de charger de ce que vous n'avez
jamais senti etc
je me dis mais si effectivement à
l'école on contribue à détruire les
identités qu'on contribue à ne pas aider
à la formation d'une identité
alors évidemment on va fabriquer des
enfants qui seront douloureux qui seront
souffrent ça paraît évident vous avez
été adolescent j'étais adolescent tout
le monde a été adolescent chacun se
souvient de cette période est difficile
on a une voix qui mue on a une espèce de
corps d'adulte avec un goût de moustache
qui on commence à avoir une voix de
fille une voix de fausses ip d'un seul
coup on a une voix grave si ça dérape
il ya des moments hormonaux il ya des
mouvements de changement dans un corps
dans un esprit aussi le cerveau est dans
une espèce de bain hormonal donc il n'ya
pas de cerveau pour les gens qui sont
des familiers de la théorie du genre y'a
pas d'hormones ça n'existe pas non plus
il ya pas de chromosomes n'y a pas de
gêne y'a rien de tout ça il ya une
espèce de cire vierge qui fait que si
vous voulez si vous naissez
hypothétiquement petit garçon si vous
voulez être une fille a aucun problème
et 6 à 4 ans vous en arrivez à cette
idée que votre corps n'est pas votre
corps que c'est le corps d'un autre que
vous habitez le corps d'un tiers mais
que voudriez change et deux tiers
je pense que ce n'est pas les enfants
qui sont qui sont coupables ce sont les
parents qui n'est pas la constitution
d'une entité ceci dit je ne suis pas
contre le fait que plus tard des gens
aient envie de changer de sexe je n'ai
rien contre ça parce que je pense que
quand études affaire d'adultes quote
c'est devenu effectivement quelque chose
qui a été nourri pensé conçu par soi
même vécu éventuellement dans la
souffrance par soi même jeu
je n'ai rien à dire je pense que les
villes transsexuels peuvent être dans
des souffrances et ont légitimement le
droit de pouvoir changer de sexe je
trouve ça tout à fait normal
ce que je ne trouve pas normal c'est
qu'on puisse estimer que ça pourrait
être un choix à l'heure où les identités
ne sont pas constitués donc
effectivement je pars d'un moment comme
celui-ci et j'estime que le jour où
effectivement dans les écoles françaises
on peut faire des reportages où on
montre des instituteurs payés avec
l'argent du contribuable qui s'en
viennent instiller le doute sur le sur
l'identité des enfants dans une école
je pense effectivement que en et au delà
des études du genre on est au delà de la
théorie du genre
on est dans la propagande du genre mais
vous pourriez belle idée michel onfray
je suis sûr que vous ne seriez pas
contre l'idée que autrefois on aurait pu
envoyer un instituteur pour distiller le
doute par exemple sur les croyances
religieuses des élèves
il était persuadé d'être catholique
croyant chrétien
tout simplement parce que leurs parents
l'étaient et on aurait pu leur dire mais
est-ce que tu l'aies vraiment et après
tout ce ne serait pas grave que de
distiller le doute puisque il pourrait
très bien ensuite une fois adulte
changer d'avis ou changer de religion ou
revenir à leur religion etc etc
comme cette petite fille qui dit j'ai
envie de changer de sexe enfant on l'a
pas opérer sur la table de la classe on
la laisse dire qu'elle aimerait changer
de sexe et puis on verra bien le jour où
elle est adulte elle aura même temps si
elle le veut de changer d'avis ne croyez
vous pas non pas quand pas qu'on est
dedans que quand on est comme ça dans
une ambiance où on est devenue l'héroïne
de changement de sexe quand on a 8 ans
et qu'on dit qu'on est travaillée par
cette question là depuis quatre ans je
pense que le doute vous avez raison il
faut de l'enseigné mais à un certain âge
était professeur de philo pendant 20 ans
pensez bien que le doute c'était ma
méthode
un prof de philo digne de ce nom il est
il est socratique
il interpelle les élèves y les
questionne fait fonctionner le doute
mais c'est un doute méthodique pour
reprendre l'expression de descartes dire
c'est pas une fin en soi le doute le
doute pour le coup c'est une méthode
pour qu'on parvienne à quelque chose
d'autre
moi j'aime beaucoup les livres de morale
de la troisième république et de l'école
républicaine et il était construit
crescendo c'est à dire qu'il fallait
enseigner aux enfants certain nombre de
choses qui ne sont pas forcément des ne
sont pas restés des valeurs aujourd'hui
mais il y avait un moment donné où on
arrivait à dieu et on enseignait pas le
dieu de la bible on enseigner pas le le
dieu d'isaac et de jacob pour utiliser
l'expression de pascal mais le dieu des
philosophes c'est à dire que c'était le
dieu de benjamin franklin et on
enseignait en france une espèce de des
ismes laïque et républicain on
enseignait pas l'athéisme l'enseigné un
certain type de dieu qui n'était pas
forcément le dieu du coran qui n'était
pas le dieu de l'ancien testament ou du
nouveau testament
donc on peut imaginer que ceux des ismes
là j'ai l'occasion de ne pas faire fi de
la transcendance chez un enfant
il ya un goût pour le sacré il ya un
goût pour la transcendance et un goût
pour ce que dit chapelle les arrières
monde ne peut pas faire comme s'il n'y
avait rien de tout cela
donc on peut envisager que en puissance
est née des spiritualités par une
spiritualité en disant c'est la seule
c'est la bonne mais des spiritualités le
défenseur de la civilisation que je suis
et le défenseur des civilisations et
j'estime que plus il y aura de
civilisation plus il y aurait la
civilisation mieux ce serait plus j
dilla d'espèces animales plus les gens
sont contents je vois pas pourquoi
plus il ya de langue plus les gens sont
contents mais d'un seul coup il faudrait
qu'il y ait peu de civilisation et qu'on
finisse par une seule civilisation qui
serait celle du consumérisme américain
avec le transhumanisme qui fait qu' on
aurait plus que dès que des projets non
je pense qu'il faut défendre des
civilisations et que si à l'école on
utilise le doute il doit être méthodique
pour parvenir à un certain type de
vérité qui rendent possible la vie
sociale la vie commune la vie
communautaire
on est passé d'un excès effectivement
l'école républicaine enseigner la
soumission de la subjectivité à la
totalité ou à la collectivité
aujourd'hui c'est très exactement l
inverse on a totalement inversé les
valeurs et on estime qu'il faut
soumettre la collectivité la communauté
au subjectivité et qui plus ou
subjectivité minoritaires
quant aux villes écrit dans la
démocratie en amérique que la démocratie
est une catastrophe parce que c'est de
la tyrannie des mines des majorités de
la majorité jeudi mais ce serait
formidable qu'on ait la tyrannie la
majorité or là on à la tyrannie des
minorités je ne dis pas que les
transsexuels n'existe pas et ne devrait
pas exister ou que c'est une anomalie
coûts etc etc je dis qu'ils sont
minoritaires et qu' ils ont droit à un
traitement de faveur
bien sûr mais sans imaginer que cette
minorité devrait pouvoir devenir une
majorité
je pense que c'est la même chose avec
tout ce qui a été marges chez les
philosophes de la déconstruction ça pu
être g2 le schizophrène chez foucault le
fou larmes aphrodite aussi chez foucault
le prisonnier chez foucault également on
a estimé que d'un seul coup il fallait
en finir avec le centre de la page et
faire de telle sorte que les mages les
marges devienne le centre
je ne suis pas de ceux qui disent que
c'était bien que le centre ignore les
marges mais je pense que les marges
ignorant le centre c'est pas bien non
plus il faudrait donc faire de telle
sorte qu'on puisse avoir un équilibre
entre eux les marges et le centre pour
faire de telle sorte que chacun puisse
trouver le l'occasion de fabriquer une
communauté nous fabriquons plus de
communauté on est dans une somme de
l'autisme encore que l'autisme de
l'utilisation du mot va m'être reprochée
mais de solipsisme je dirais et une
somme de solipsisme chacun étant lui
même sa propre femme rangée bien droit
je veux bien j'ai envie le matin de me
réveiller comme un garçon le midi d'être
une fille l'après-midi éventuellement de
changer depuis le soir d'être dans la
détermination et j'ai bien le droit de
ça et parfois on agresse le prof qui m'a
dit non ne m'appelez pas monsieur je
suis madame et qui appelle madame
quelqu'un qui décide dans l'après midi
qu'il est devenu neutre et et le square
redemandera qu'on l'appelle madame etc
il ya un moment donné où les caprices
solipsiste ne peuvent pas faire la loi
d'une collectivité ou d'une communauté
on enseignait jadis qu'il n'y avait pas
de subjectivité mais que de la
communauté
aujourd'hui on enseigne inverse il n'y a
que des subjectivités et aucune
communauté
le des colonialismes l'indigénisme ça
aussi ça fait partie de ce que l'on
appelle l'islamo gauchisme vous le
dénoncé à plusieurs reprises dans la nef
des fous
en même temps quand je vous lis j'ai
l'impression qu'il a
il ronge notre société jusqu'au plus
haut sommet de l'état or le des
colonialismes est combattu par jean
michel blanquer repas dominique vidal
par gérald darmanin par les
intellectuels pierre nora marcel gaucher
je dirais les trois quarts voire les
quatre cinquièmes des intellectuels sont
contre les indigéniste l'heure les
militants a dit j'ai dit ce ne sont
jamais invités à la télévision dans son
cul des missions d'une part comment là
aussi expliquez vous qu'il fasse à tête
de tels ravages
je ne regarde pas tout la télévision je
ne sais pas s'il existe à la télévision
pas ceci dit la télévision c'est plus là
où ça se fait aujourd'hui je pense que
il ya des télévisions alternatives et
des chaînes youtube et des occasions de
communiquer qui ne passe pas par là par
la télévision
soral n'ai jamais invité la télévision
il a un nombre considérable de gens qui
sont abonnés à sa chaîne youtube
alain de benoist n'ai jamais invité à la
télévision et il a aussi des lecteurs
pensent que la télévision n'est pas le
lieu d'expression de d2 de la totalité
de la vie intellectuelle vous savez très
bien vous avez été l'un des animateurs
de cette vie culturelle et voilà enfin
je voudrais parler d'autres cas mais
quand on prend par exemple le viol de
500 femmes en allemagne à 31 décembre ça
a été analysé par les indigènes de la
nuit qui nous ont expliqué que vaut bien
deux catégories du genre il ya un
violeur ce qu'un et des violets
ce sont des victimes
ces catégories là ne sont plus les
bonnes et bonne catégorie c'est de
savoir si on et racisées ou si on est
parent à 6 et le violeur était-il
racisées s'il l'était alors ce n'est pas
un violeur ce n'est pas mon explication
mais je vous la donne et elle est quand
même assez sidérante
j'ai lu chez houria bouteldja et chez
quelques d'autres que j'ai quelques
autres que rokhaya diallo par exemple
j'ai lu que c'est elle ces garçons qui
étaient violeur arabo musulman et il dit
c'est l'expression qui est donné pour
les qualifier ces arabo musulman quand
il violé parce qu'ils étaient racisées
ne faisait jamais que recouvrait par la
violence ce que les blancs leur avait
ôté par une autre violence cette fameuse
contre violence que sartre théorise dans
la critique de la raison dialectique
cette fameuse contre violence
elle est une violence légitime aux yeux
de ces gens là pour une raison bien
simple c'est que il y a eu colonisation
et cette colonisation a fait que les
blés blanc quoi qu'ils fassent ont
toujours tort et les noirs je mets des
guillemets à tout ça quoi qu'ils fassent
ont toujours raison
pour une raison très freudienne pour le
coup c'est freud qui rend possible ce
genre de sottises
parce que finalement les inconscients
communiquerez et se transmettrait de
manière phylogénétique c'est à dire que
si à trois siècles quatre siècles dans
votre famille il y a eu un traumatisme
ce traumatisme et l'est toujours dans
votre propre conscient moyennant quoi
vous dites mais en 14 192 les blancs
sont arrivés aux antilles et ont
massacré un certain nombre de population
créole de sorte que moi dans mon
inconscient en 2020 mois qui suivent
mais un black par exemple eh bien il y à
ce traumatisme
et il ya même des gens qui explique que
ce traumatisme n'est pas que
psychologique ou psychique mais qu'il
est aussi physiologique qu'il est
également anatomiques donc ça veut dire
que quoi que vous fassiez vous êtes du
côté du bien
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez y
compris violet ou vous êtes du côté du
mal vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
vous faire violer aussi de toute façon
vous avez tort donc on estime que les
violeurs pour le coup était en train de
recouvrer une violence que les blancs
leur avait ôté c'était donc une certaine
contre violence qui disposait de sa
légitimité
pendant que cette femme elle elle
descendait des blancs qui eux mêmes
avaient infligé cette violence au peuple
qu'on dit aujourd'hui racisées s'éteint
c'est une annonce était évidemment de
démonstration qui n'est pas la mienne je
rapporte simplement cette démonstration
pour expliquer que quand on vous dit
effectivement que des femmes qui se font
violer sont des coupables pendant que
des hommes qui les violent le viol sont
des victimes
j'estime effectivement que c'est assez
problématique d'en appeler aux des
colonialismes de mobiliser michel
foucault ou jacques derrida pour ces
choses là mais michel onfray il nous
reste juste une minute avant de faire
une pause mais on a utilisé à peu près
les mêmes procédés pour excusé au nom de
la lutte des classes
le fait que des des bonnes assassinent
leurs patrons que des ouvriers s'en
prennent à la bourgeoisie c'est une
vieille antienne de savoir que la
victime aurait des excuses pas des
droits mais des excuses à mal se
comporter vis-à-vis de ceux qui l'ont
qui en ont fait une victime justement
mais il nous reste juste une minute à
queen pause
oui ces statuts de la contrevenante si
vous voulez faisons notre pause et on
reparlera de la contre violence et du
statut de la violence chez engels et
chez sartre et quelques autres qui
estiment effectivement quelle est la
coucheuse de l'histoire ont fait une
pause on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire pourrait creuser
encore un peu plus les inégalités entre
les plus riches et les plus pauvres il y
à un million de pauvres en plus on est
passé de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim nous ne sommes pas en
france on a l'impression d'être en train
de passer dans un pays du tiers-monde le
problème il est bien en amont il est
depuis que les banques centrales
intrigues de l'argent et quand l intérim
de l'argent en fait ça ne va pas dans
l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
la cause de la paupérisation de la
france de la tiers-mondisation sur la
glande s'engage si la destruction de
l'industrie française réindustrialiser
c'est pas juste en claquant des doigts
vous faites revenir les sociétés d'abord
il faut changer complètement tout c'est
à dire tout ce qui les a fait partir il
ya une débauche d'argent qu'on met sur
le sur la table sans se préoccuper de
savoir qui au final va payer au final
c'est toujours les mêmes les dindons de
la farce c'est toujours les mêmes vers
qui on va se tourner pour aller payer la
note
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara fuyant la france
comme l'europe a été absente de
l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume du
maroc des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées
[Musique]
voilà de retour avec michel onfray
puisqu'on parlait de contre violence
vous vous en prenez dans la nef des fous
à ceux qui vandalisent les statuts que
ce soit celles de deux du roi léopold ii
qui était propriétaire du congo et qui
n'étaient pas toujours très tendre c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire avec ses
habitants ou celle d'edouard cold stone
qui était à marchands d'esclaves et vous
dites ils se comportent comme des
talibans qui détruisaient les les
statues bouddhistes mais est-ce que
c'est véritablement la même chose michel
onfray ceux qui ont renversé les statuts
d'hitler de lénine ou de staline
est-ce qu'ils étaient eux aussi étaient
des vandales personne ne les a jamais
vus comme tel non on peut imaginer
effectivement que ma un certain nombre
de statues qui s'effondre c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle une bonne chose il me
semble effectivement que les statues de
lénine de staline ou d'hitler sais pas
si j'ai d'ailleurs beaucoup de statues
d'hitler mais enfin les des statuts des
dictateurs qui qui tombe c'est une bonne
chose mais il ya juste un moment où vous
dites
par exemple quand en martinique victor
victor schoelcher et est attaqué c'est
pas adolf hitler c'est pas staline c'est
pas un tyran c'est pamarot c'est juste
un personnage qui a travaillé à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
on se dit mais comment est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut on peut tenir
dans une même estime quelqu'un qui
travaille à l'aube à l'abolition de
l'esclavagé est un indicateur comme
staline par exemple est juste un moment
donné où il faut comprendre que ce qu'on
reproche à schoelcher ça n'est pas
d'avoir était l'abolitionniste que l'on
sait c'est d'avoir récupéré la cause
abolitionniste qui aurait été uniquement
la cause des noirs on se dit mais il
suffit juste de demander à l'histoire
qu'elles témoignent où sont les
révolutions qui auront été des
révolutions anti esclavagiste qui nous
aurait permis de dire a effecté
effectivement ils ont tordu le bras à
tous ces gens de à tous ces gens de à
tous et blond de 2,2 de la métropole et
puis c'est un combat qu'on leur aura
volé c'est pas l'histoire c'est pas le
sens du pardon de vous interrompre mais
c'est le cas en aux antilles
l'esclavagé a été aboli avant l'arrivée
du décret de schoelcher simplement parce
que les esclaves se sont révoltés et il
ya eu des révoltes d'esclaves enfin
saint domingue et ceux qui avaient
vandalisé la statue churn on voulait pas
et chercheurs ils ont voulu au fait qu
on dressait des statuts un blanc qui
avait aboli l esclavage et pas à ce
qu'ils avaient
vaincus ou en tout cas combattu dans le
sang mais vous savez les révolutions de
tiananmen quand elles n'ont pas abouti
c'est parce que le pouvoir n'a pas voulu
qu'ils aboutissent et un certain nombre
de révolutions qui n'aboutissent pas
simplement parce que vous avez les
dictateurs qui tirent si louis saez
avait tiré la révolution française
aurait-elle eu lieu donc il ya juste un
moment donné ou ne me faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai pas dit oui il ya eu
effectivement des bd appelons ça des
mouvements révolutionnaires contre
contre l' esclavage mais ces mouvements
ont rendu possibles l'abolitionnisme qui
est un combat de la gauche de cette
époque là donc ça se tient donc moi je
ne suis pas contre le fait qu'on puisse
ériger des monuments en l'honneur de des
gens de couleur des martiniquais qui ont
travaillé à l'abolition de l'esclavagé
alors ça au contraire
faisons le je suis pour qu'on augmente
les statuts mais pas pour qu'on détruise
des statuts je pense qu'on se trompe de
combat quand on estime que ce qui était
à l'époque la gauche mais mène un combat
anticolonialiste qui est une bonne chose
et bien c'est un c'est un compagnonnage
qu'il faut faire c'est pas une
opposition c'est à dire d'un côté on ne
peut pas vouloir détruire la statue de
schelcher sous prétexte qu'il est et
qu'il a aboli l'esclavagé puis après ça
ne pas vouloir célébrer napoléon qui
resterait l'escale qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut juste dire que ont fait de
l'idéologie ne fait pas de l'histoire
dans cette aventure
on a juste envie de détruire des statuts
de plans parce qu'on estime qu'ils sont
blancs et qu'on n'a plus envie qu'ils
fassent l'histoire l'histoire n'est pas
la leur c'est qu'il en fait on n'a pas
envie et on s'en débarrasse
moi je suis pour le fait qu'on conserve
ses statuts et qu'on ajoute d'autres
statues qu'on nous fasse découvrir une
autre histoire qu'on nous fasse savoir
qu'il ya eu des génies méconnus des gens
oubliés des révolutionnaires qui ont
contribué à la cause abolitionniste et
c'est une bonne chose je suis moi même
probablement victime de mon éducation
qui fait que je ne connais pas le détail
de ces combats là je vais souvent en
martinique j'achète des livres qu'on ne
trouve que là bas qui sont extrêmement
intéressants et qui montre qu'il ya
effectivement des scientifiques et
d'iliad et des agronomes qu'il y a les
gens dont on ne parle pas effectivement
dans l'est dans la pays d'hommes dans la
civilisation judéo-chrétienne blanche
si je suis prêt à le le sahara le
en convenir puisque je voulais lui je le
vois ces choses là m'intéressent
je dis simplement que sur le mode de la
violence ça ne m'intéresse pas cette
violence qui a été générée par 1793 le
tribunal révolutionnaire
la terreur a rendu possible un marx
lui-même estime que la mac c'est à
engels qui estime que la violence est
accoucheuses de l'histoire et qu'elle
est nécessaire et qu'elle est même utile
et puis on arrive à un sartre qui estime
qu' après après la tcheka l'union
soviétique le goulag et c'est que la
violence révolutionnaire n'est jamais
qu'une contre-révolution qu'une contre
violence et que cette recontre violence
est légitime parce que ça n'est pas la
même chose de d'égorger quelqu'un parce
qu'il aurait été un fils de
d'exploiteurs ou un exploiteur lui-même
plutôt que de dégorger un esclave je
suis très camusien sur ce terrain là
j'estime que un homme ça s'empêche que
tout ce qui est destruction statut qui
s'appelle vandalisme destruction de
livres c'est aussi du vandalisme
interdiction de conférences super lent
distincts jeu peu suspect de défendre
françois hollande mais quand françois
hollande est interdit de faire une
conférence dans une université et qu'on
déchire son livre et bien c'est pas
françois hollande que je défends c'est
pas le livre de françois hollande que je
défends c'est la possibilité pour un
homme de pouvoir s'exprimer de pouvoir
dire ce qu'il pense et pour d'autres la
possibilité de les faire savoir qu'ils
ne sont pas d'accord en débattant avec
des arguments intellectuelle mais ça
c'est vrai à vous signaler des abus il y
en a dans dans tous les domaines mais
quand vous dites que vous n'êtes peuvent
vous vous êtes contre le déboulonnage
des statuts sachant que ça n'est pas de
la violence le déboulonnage des statuts
alors ce serait une violence symbolique
quand on déboulonne ce une statue même
si c'est parce qu'il est parce que la
personne était blanche
ça n'est pas attaqué des gens vivant
parce qu'ils sont blancs
mais vous même avez établi une partie de
votre réputation intellectuelle sur le
déboulonnage de statut quand vous vous
attaquez à freud ou à au marquis de sade
vous vous attaquez vous y attaquer
vraiment vous déboulonner leur statut ce
sont des dés ce qu'on pourrait qualifier
de vaches sacrées ou de monstres sacrés
dans notre civilisation
or vous les attaquer et vous ne faites
pas de quartier à ce moment là oui vous
avez je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
effectivement que le déboulonnage d'un
certain nombre de statues mme paraissait
utile et nécessaire
c'est bien que je n'ai jamais aimé chez
ca de la violence sexuelle l'éloge du
viol l'éloge de la paix diffuserait de
phily l'éloge de la zoophilie l'éloge du
crime l'éloge du meurtre était terrain
bon effectivement j'ai jamais non plus
aimé staline j'ai jamais non plus aimé
lénine ai jamais aimé non plus un mao
je n'ai pas non plus aimé saddam hussein
et ça a fait partie des statuts que j'ai
que j'ai volontiers fait tomber mais
j'ai pas fait tomber d'un tout
toute l'histoire de la philosophie
occidentale j'ai fait douze ou treize
volumes d'une contre histoire de la
philosophie où j'ai révélé l'existence
d'un certain nombre de philosophes dont
on ne parle jamais ou de gens qu'on
connaît simplement pour un livre une
réputation jean marie guyot son esquisse
d'une morale sans obligation ni sanction
ou alors les philosophes comme anti
fonds d'athènes dont on parle assez peu
ou des gens comme les frères et soeurs
du libre esprit
donc je n'ai pas fait que détruire des
statures j'ai érigé aussi des statues
c'est la même chose avec freud veut dire
cette idée que je veux pas rentrer dans
le détail vous pourrez passer une heure
sur freud mais cette idée que freud se
représenter comme un grand libérateur
des femmes alors qu'il ya pas plus
misogyne que lui un grand libérateur du
sexe alors qu'il estimait que les
homosexuels étaient des gens raté est
arrêté en route un personnage qui aurait
défendu toute libération sexuelle alors
que finalement ils défendent est très
exactement inverse la répression la
répression politique qui ait eu des
sympathies pour mussolini qu'il ait des
sympathies pour le chancelier de le fuse
qui était un austro fasciste
ça me paraît normal de dire vous avez le
droit d'aimer freud mais sachez que
fraude c'est ça et puis aimé le pour ce
qu'il est mais il n'est pas du tout un
grand libérateur des femmes c'est au
contraire un réactionnaire qui ne soigne
pas les pauvres ce qui estimait qu'il y
avait un bénéfice à la maladie et qui
prenait très cher
pour me soigner un certain nombre de
riches en sachant très bien que sa
psychanalyse ne fonctionnait pas c'est
ce qu'il dit lui même dans sa
correspondance en disant que c'était un
blanchiment de donc je détruis pas
les statuts pour le plaisir de détruire
des statuts quand je détruis la statue
freud j'ai vu l'oeuvre complète de freud
c'est à dire que je vais j'ai fait la
même chose avec sade jeu j'estime faire
un travail informer un travail
d'historien de contre histoire pour le
coup mais pour moi le problème c'est de
proposer des contres histoire c'est pas
de d'effacer toute l'histoire je pense
que tout ça se tient quand vous parler
de ces choses là comme si c'était des
choses séparées c'est bien que vous ne
le fait pas mais que c'est le principe
de l'entretien mais tout ça se tient
dans une même configuration qui est la
haine du passé et la réécriture du passé
on est très exactement dans la
perspective de d'orwell 1 mais quand on
veut déboulonner la statue de colbert on
n'efface pas colbert on n'efface pas
l'histoire
l'institut la statue fication c'est une
lecture de l'histoire à la gloire d'un
certain nombre de grands personnalité du
passé qui se révèle parce que les
époques changent parce que les jugements
change tout à coup on a peut-être eu
tort de lui ériger une statue est au
fond le travail qui n'est pas fait de la
manière aussi érudite que vous l'avez
fait vous sur freud mais le travail qui
est fait sur colbert est du même ordre
c'est de dire ben voilà le type que vous
rêvez ray depuis longtemps il est
peut-être pas aussi bien que vous le
dites pas écouté je viens de faire un
livre sur de gaulle et mitterrand
il s'appelle le vie parallèle une
françois mitterrand était très compagnon
de la cagoule un groupement enfin une
acti menu une espèce de sectes d'extrême
droite très opposés à des maîtres à la
démocratie et qui faisait l'éloge de la
violence justement il a été vite schiste
il a été maréchaliste il a été
pétainiste il a été géré audistes il a
été le compagnon d'un certain nombre d'
extrême ni de gens d'extrême droite
pendant toute son existence
le dernier repas qu'il fait à l'elysée
c'est en compagnie de jean d'ormesson
est quand même un grand bavard dans
paris et il lui parle à ce moment-là de
la formidable puissance du lobby juif
c'est à dire que du début jusqu'à la fin
cet homme qui aura été effectivement
l'extrême droite pour moi du début
jusqu'à la fin
qui aura en plus de ça trahit les
socialistes seraient ils socialisme
détruit socialisme
cet homme là effectivement n'était pas
un personnage
admirable d'un point de vue des critères
d'aujourd'hui mais je ne suis pas de
ceux qui estiment qu'il faudrait
débaptiser la bibliothèque françois
mitterrand je ne crois pas que ce serait
très intelligent de le faire simplement
il faut faire de l'histoire
eh bien je préférerais que des gens
puissent nous faire un bon livre sur
colbert nous expliquant pourquoi ce
combo colbert était détestable fasse une
contre histoire de colbert si vous
voulez utiliser mon vocabulaire plutôt
que d'estimer qu' en faisant tomber et
une statue on aura réglé le problème
parce qu'un jour on fait tomber une
statue puis après on fait tomber un
homme
et puis après quand l'homme est tombé et
bien en me donne des coups puis après
quand au milieu des coups on lui coupe
la tête et puis et c'est assez tard ça
commence comme ça parce que on commence
par voler des livres puis on finit par
brûler ce qu'ils écrivent les livres on
commence par décapiter des statuts puis
après on continue par décapiter des
hommes sous prétexte qu'ils seraient
issus de la pensée de cet homme qui
avait été statufié je trouve que tout ce
qui est violence aujourd'hui est une
mauvaise chose
on est en train de répandre de la poudre
partout et je crois qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a des crépitements d'étincelles
c'est une catastrophe pour l'histoire je
ne parle même pas de civilisation mais
je pense que on peut s'écouter
on peut s'entendre on peut débattre on
peut expliquer faire des colloques des
bouquins faire avancer ses idées montré
que caleb que colbert était un sale type
tout ce qu'on veut je veux bien tout ça
il est tout à fait audible et
défendables et même expliqué que
schoelcher était une catastrophe était
là mais il faudrait tout faire
c'est bien il faudrait aussi que la
gauche puisse expliquer que quand elle
colonise quand elle colonise de
l'algérie par exemple elle le fait parce
que jules ferry qui est un homme de
gauche a décidé qu'il fallait le faire
et à ce moment-là supprimer toutes les
écoles jules ferry les rues jules-ferry
toutes les mentions de jules ferry et
c'est donc il ya un moment donné où
quand on commence on ne sait plus où
s'arrêter c'est à dire il n'y a pas une
figure historique qui tiendra le coup et
on enlèvera toutes les plaques des rues
on détruira tout les statuts on détruira
tous les portraits on brûlera toutes les
peintures on cassera toutes les statues
qui ont constitué notre civilisation
judéo-chrétienne
je pense que le but c'est un peu ça
c'est d'illustrer ce terrible propos du
passé faisons table rase j'ai
l'impression quand on quand on vous lit
en tout cas quand on lit la nef des fous
et même le numéro 4 2
de la revue front populaire qui vient de
paraître que au fond ce qui est en train
de deux peut-être de conduire notre
civilisation naufrage vient souvent de
l'extérieur en fait c'est souvent dans
des apports de l'extérieur qui viennent
ébranler au fond notre confort
intellectuel mais on pourrait dire aussi
que ça vient de l'intérieur
après tout on est une civilisation
vieillissante la démographie n'est plus
vraiment de notre côté en 1900 les
européens représentait un homme sur
quatre sur terre c'est pour ça qu'ils
auront pu conquérir l'afrique aussi
facilement il y avait 100 millions de
gens en afrique est un continent
totalement vide
évidemment les choses sont en train de
devenir différentes aujourd'hui et dans
en 2050 si l'on regarde les projections
plus d'un homme sur deux sera viatique
un sur cinq sera africain et les
européens
même les blancs en général ce sera plus
qu'un homme sur neuf donc forcément va
devenir à notre tour une minorité et ça
ça ne vient pas de l'extérieur c'est de
nous mêmes ah oui je suis entièrement
d'accord
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de
segalen en vous disant que c'est l
analyse que segalen faisait sur la
disparition pour expliquer la
disparition des marquises c'est
l'effondrement de d'une civilisation sur
elle-même qui fait que cette
civilisation disparaît que d'autres
peuvent peuvent peuvent s'installer de
fait moi j'ai rien contre les les
migrants ou les immigrés j'ai rien
contre l'islam
je dis simplement que l'église étant
devenue ce qu'elle est devenue je
comprends que la spiritualité se soit
effondré comme elle s'est effondrée
c'est vraiment quand on voit ce qu'est
vatican ii dont je reste at et ne vous
inquiétez pas mais quand on voit ce qu'a
été vatican ii on se dit effectivement
que l'église n'existe plus que on a
aujourd'hui un pas de france quad on
dont on n'entend jean luc mélenchon dire
que il est un pas très bien qu'il y des
choses très intéressantes enfin on
marche sur la tête
est ce que je sais pas est ce que pol 6
aurait dit georges marchais qu'il était
un personnage formidable
on imagine que non donc je pense
effectivement que c'est ainsi moi je
suis pas réactionnaires je suis pas
conservateur non plus je ne suis pas un
optimiste de com comme je sais pas les
les gens comme les gens qui votent le
pen ou peut-être eric zemmour en
estimant qu' il faut arrêter tout ça il
faut faire marche arrière et et en
faisant ceci et cela en expulsant des
gens en interdisant d'autres personnes
en réglant le problème avec des miradors
au des frontières en sauvera notre
civilisation non je suis suis pas
pessimiste pour autant mais je suis un
tragique jeu je joue je bougeais l'âge
qui me permet d'envisager avec la
culture que j'ai pu emmagasiner en des
années de travail de lecture des
magazines et des savoirs qui me
permettent de mieux penser ce que je
pouvais penser quand j'avais 20 ans
c'est à dire que quand je lisais malraux
à 20 ans et qu'il parlait d'un sur le
super de babylone des sites les hittites
etc
je ne suivais pas trop mais parce que je
comprenais pas tout et puis quand j'ai
fait ma thèse sur un parti sur spengler
je ne comprenais pas tout non plus parce
que quand il parle des des mathématiques
des ioniens et qui le met en relation
avec les mathématiques baroque
si on ne sait pas ce que sont les
mathématiques des philosophes ioniens
est ce que ce sont aussi des
mathématiques baroque on comprend pas
grand chose et puis à un moment donné où
quand on a suffisamment de cultures et
de hauteur on peut comprendre ce que
hegel a pu écrire sur les civilisations
à ce moment-là dire mais c'est ce qui
nous arrive donc ce qui nous arrive
c'est comme c'est comme imaginer qu un
papy de 99 ans qui est en train de
mourir
il faudrait lui trouver des médicaments
pour qu'il retrouve les lll est la vertu
et la jeunesse et la virilité et la
libido de ses 20 ans mais non c'est 1,6
il faut passer la main il ya eu 1 /
sumer babylone j'ai vu l'egypte ya eu
les les grecs et les romains il ya
l'europe l'europe vous avez raison vous
avez donné tous les tous les arguments
qui qui justifie cette thèse l'europe
s'en vint la civilisation
judéo-chrétienne disparaît et ça ne
servira à rien de dire qu'il faudrait
restaurer un ordre ancien je n'y crois
pas je crois qu'on peut être une espèce
de dandy à la bo de l'air en disant vas
mourir debout
mais on peut aussi de temps en temps
être lucide dire qu'on est lucide faire
savoir qu'on n'est pas dupe et puis
faire son travail du philosophe qui est
de comme disait nietzsche de nuire à la
bêtise justement votre votre nef des
fous 7 vous l'avez dit ça se passe
pendant toute l'année 2020 et cette
année de bill va était particulièrement
riche en événement sans précédent
je pense évidemment à la crise du que
vides et on a bien vu que la crise du
coc bid montraient que nous n'étions
plus les plus forts que nous n'étions
plus les plus modernes que nous n'étions
plus non plus les plus libres et que
bientôt nous ne serons plus les plus
riches mais on restera les mieux armés
peut-être que ça certains y tiennent
d'ailleurs ça pourrait peut-être
retarder ce naufrage vous dire les mieux
armés dans quel sens c'est que les
l'otan ça reste la plus grande puissance
militaire et surtout l'amérique et la
super super puissance militaire et que
donc même si nous sommes moins nombreux
même si nous ne sommes plus à la pointe
pour gérer des épidémies même s'il ça
n'est plus nous qui en voyant des avions
pour sauver les autres mais ce serait
plutôt nous qui attendrions ici qu'on
nous envoie des masques on est quand
même les mieux armés on a encore la
technologie
alors quand je vous faisais préciser
parce que je ne savais pas si c'était
métaphorique les mieux armés ou si
c'était au sens premier du terme au sens
militaire ça il ya un très gros livre de
clausewitz ce qui s'appelle de la guerre
qui fait cinq ou six cents pages qu'on
ne peut plus lire aujourd'hui ça ne
présente plus aucun intérêt sauf quand
vous êtes dans une école de guerre parce
que clausewitz vous raconte ce
qu'étaient les les guerres
napoléoniennes et puis les guerres
anciennes junger à bien penser la
question de la guerre quand elle est
devenue mécanique à partir de 14 18 et
il ya quelque chose dont clausewitz
parle peu mais c'est un tout petit texte
d'une petite conférence à se trouve pas
dans de la guerre mais c'est un
sex-appeal de la guérilla ce qu'il
appelle la petite guerre et je pense que
nous nous trompons en imaginant que il
nous faut des armes qui ne serviront à
rien c'est à dire que si les conflits
arrive par exemple avec la turquie par
exemple avec la chine
ils n'arriveront pas de sur le principe
nucléaire ça nous servira à rien d'avoir
un porte-avions qui d'ailleurs à une
hélice trop grande qui d'ailleurs à des
fuites nucléaires qui d'ailleurs a des
problèmes da ponte âge qu'on est obligée
d'allonger enfin je sais que on est un
peu comique avec nos armements
ça ne sont passés ce ne sont pas ses
armes dans la qui seront en jeu dans les
prochaines guerres ce seront des petites
guerres c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui a décidé avec internet
en achetant cinq ou six produits qu'on
trouve dans des drogueries de fabriquer
une bombe artisanale qu'il va placer
dans un endroit après je veux pas
rentrer dans les détails mais qui
pourrait faire des massacres
que peut faire un porte-avions français
des plats un porte-avions ou une charge
nucléaire par exemple qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire contre ça rien c'est à dire
que ça ne sert à rien d'avoir une hyper
technologies quand la grande guerre
n'existe plus que seule la petite guerre
existe et qu'on est incapable d'y
répondre
à quoi ça sert que nous ayons
aujourd'hui la bombe atomique puisque
nous ne sommes pas capables de respect
de faire respecter l'ordre dans un
certain nombre de banlieue c'est à dire
que d'un certain nombre de deux jeunes
aujourd'hui font des tirs de mortier à
partir de 2 2 normalement de produits
dérivés puisque ce sont des choses qui
servent au feu d'artifice
et bien aujourd'hui l'armée française
est en tête en difficulté à l'endroit de
jeunes qui utilisent les tirs de
mortiers de feux d'artifice
donc hier avant de nous il faut arrêter
dans les écoles de guerre de croire que
l'on va encore s'opposer sur le mode de
la guerre froide à la russie à la
turquie à la chine c'est quoi c'est
n'importe quoi
ferions mieux de collaborer avec avec la
russie d'imaginer ce qui est
envisageable
justement avec une grande perspective
européenne à l'endroit de la turquie
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui une
manière très impérialiste et ça ça
suppose de la diplomatie et je pense que
plutôt que d'avoir des bombes atomiques
efficace nous ferions mieux de vous
une diplomatie nous avons eu longtemps
une école diplomatique française le
français a longtemps été la langue
diplomatique la diplomatie aujourd'hui
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi
où sont nos grands diplomates si à
hubert védrine qui est un personnage
remarquable mais mais où sont-ils les
autres qui seraient susceptibles
justement d'avoir des postes qui
rendrait possible justement d'aider des
interactions entre de notre civilisation
et d'autres civilisations qui sont dans
des logiques de tectonique des plaques
je pense que les notre armée ne sert pas
à grand chose
une égard aux conflits qui sont les
nôtres où les goûts de conflit réel d'un
de guerre civile en france de 10 mille
mille endroits qui sont des territoires
perdus de la république on n'est pas
capable de les restaurer la république
dans ces quartiers là à quoi ça sert
d'avoir ces bombes atomiques
regardez dans ce village qui a été
ravagée par une coulée de boue qui a
perdu son pont etc
j'ai vu un mois plus tard que des gens
étaient encore en train d'une rive
l'autre de se passer des nourritures
avec un système de cordes et de filins
c'est une armée digne de ce nom et la
rive et le génie des pois un pont et 24
heures plus tard on peut passer d'une
rive à l'autre
c'est à dire que nous ne sommes pas
capables aujourd'hui l'installer le pont
du génie militaire qui permet à un
village coupé en deux de pouvoir
fonctionner à nouveau
non je pense que notre armée est hélas
pour hélas pour les militaires qui le
savent bien qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent
qui n'ont pas d'armes vous avez
aujourd'hui dit on un hélicoptère sur
deux qui sert de pièce pour pour l'autre
hélicoptère c'est à dire nous avons une
flotte qui est catastrophique
donc effectivement s'il s'agit de se
mettre sous le parapluie américain eh
bien ce ne sera pas comme ça gentiment
parce que les américains nous m
ce sera pour qu'on continue à aller dans
le sens de cette civilisation
transhumanistes qui est porté par les
états unis la suite de la civilisation
c'est plus l'europe se terminer c'est au
moins
le roman les états unis à quoi il faut
ajouter 1 c'est probablement la chine et
l'inde jalons frais le quotidien
libération a fait scandale cette semaine
en avec une couverture où il laissait
entendre qu'il y avait toute une partie
des électeurs de gauche qui avaient
participé à l'élection d' emmanuel
macron en 2017
manuel macron été élu par une majorité
de professeurs socialiste que toute une
partie de cet électorat de gauche
s'apprêtait à ne pas revoter macron
l'année prochaine aux élections
présidentielles et qu'il ne ferait pas
barrage au front national on a beaucoup
reproché à libération d'avoir l'air de
dire qu'il souhaitait qu'il n'y ait pas
de barrage contre le front national
vous même qu'en pensez vous qu'en
pensez-vous à la fois être cette
querelle est et du fait que que à
certain nombre de gens prétendent que
toute une partie de la gauche ne votera
pas emmanuel macron et les sera
éventuellement être élu marine le pen
mais côté je vais vous étonner mais
bravo à libération c'est pas mon genre
de le dire habituellement mais bravo
libération moi j'ai longtemps lui
libération quand libération était de
gauche avant qu'elle ne devienne journal
de bernard tapie 2d d'yves montand de
s'ignorer de vivre la crise de la
tournant de la rigueur de 83 etc
et là d'un seul coup on retrouve
effectivement un grand journal qui fait
vraiment un travail de journalisme et
qui fait pour le coup un travail de
gauche pour moi c'est à dire
effectivement de dire regardez ce qui a
lieu c'est regarder le réel il ya peu de
gens qui à gauche je regarde le réel ya
beaucoup de gens qui est qu'ils
regardent l'idéal et qui se moque du
réel et ça c'est plutôt alors lol la
droite a plutôt tendance à voir le réel
sans voir l'idéal et la gauche idéal
sans voir le réel moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est les deux c'est de ne pas céder sur
l'idéal mais en même temps voir le réel
tel qu'il est et cette couverture de
libération de trouver très bonne très
intéressante très belle et le travail de
libération très intéressant aussi sur ce
sujet parce qu'ils disent quelque chose
que qui a lieu c'est le réel moi
j'entends des gens me dire ça les vrais
amis de gauche qui me disent moi c'est
fini
moi il ya très longtemps j'ai dit mais
il
vous êtes des idiots utiles du
libéralisme dont vous mais marine le pen
devant le nez et vous finissez toujours
par voter le soir du premier tour pour
un président de la république qui de
toute façon défendre à maastricht et des
masses très chiant ça y est les gens ont
compris ils ont compris mécanisme ils
ont compris qu'on leur mente et sarkozy
vient d'être condamnée mais on s'en fout
de cette condamnation mois ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est que sarkozy soit
condamné pour avoir mis à la poubelle le
référendum des français en 2005 le
traité constitutionnel que les français
refusent
quand en 2008 il devient le traité de
lisbonne et qu'on inflige au peuple
français qui avait dit non 1 oui que
l'assemblée nationale et le et le sénat
concocte on se dit mais là ya un procès
affaire est un coup d'état
ici à ce moment là donc les gens ont
commencé à comprendre 1992 maastricht si
on est alors en voté non à maastricht on
était un fasciste on était un nazi en it
et 1p corps un paysan un sou diplômé
d'un bac moins 10 etc etc
les gens se sont fait humilier n'ont
rien dit après ça quand on disait
attendez il ya un problème vous oubliez
le peuple quand même moi quand je disais
ça dans libre pendant dans le figaro il
y avait une pleine page dans le monde
une du monde avec ma tronche comme si
j'étais en prison pour dire que je
faisais le jeu du front national trois
jours après le monde qui a refusé une
photo avec moi écrire disait très
exactement la même chose
mais ces gens-là déroulent le tapis du
front national depuis des années si on
leur dit ils nous disent que c'est nous
qui sommes des fascistes des néo
fascistes des crypto fasciste ou etc
ils ont compris enfin qu'un certain
nombre de gens ne sont plus dupes de ce
jeu là et se disent eh bien la prochaine
fois je n'irai pas donc de ne sortent
que effectivement il ya des gens qui
pourront ne pas voter macron pour faire
barrage ne pas voter pour les clients
qui ne leur plairait pas et puis
éventuellement voter même le fameux vote
révolutionnaire pour marine le pen comme
jadis chirac avait appelé à voter
mitterrand pour mettre à la porte
giscard donc je pense qu'effectivement
c'est bien que libération se soucie de
ce dossier là s'en empare réfléchissent
à cette question c'est une question
vraiment d'actualité et moi ce qui
m'étonne c'est que les gens aient pu
imaginer que que libération souhaité que
que marine le pen soit élu c'est pas
possible c'est pas dans l'adn de
libération donc ce qui est plutôt dans
l'adn d'un libération des deux d'une
gauche qui avait ma faveur à cette
époque là enfin quitter qui a toujours
ma faveur c'est effectivement de dire
attention réelle
regardez le réel si vous voulez honorer
votre idéal faites le à partir du réel
mais ne dites pas que leur elle n'a pas
eu lieu
la question michel onfray vous qu'est ce
qui vous sépare encore de marine le pen
il faudrait qu'elle est un corpus
doctrinal qui soit claire et qui soit
lisible
voilà quelqu'un qui depuis qu'elle fait
de la politique est passée par un par
tous les stades c'est à dire que est là
elle a pris le l'idéologique son père
clés en main ensuite elle a pris une
idéologie qui était celle de filippo
maintenant il écrit dans l'opinion que
finalement le rôle europe le marché tout
ça c'est formidable ça fait quand même
quelque chose de signaux et dale moi je
vote pas pour des gens je vote pour des
idées quand mélenchon était contre le
traité de maastricht colonnes
aujourd'hui nous dit qu'il est contre
pas estimé que quelqu'un peut diriger le
pays
s'inscrire dans l'histoire de france
quand il n'a pas su ce qu'était la
réalité du monde et comment il a fait
pour ne pas saisir la réalité du monde
donc marine le pen elle est une
héritière
et puis là il est en train de se dire
mais comment puis-je arrivée au pouvoir
qu'est ce que je pourrais bien dire et
qui me conduiraient etc ça n'est pas une
femme de convictions et moi je ne
voterai que pour quelqu'un qui soit
personnes de conviction merci michel
onfray d'avoir passé toute cette édition
avec nous la nef des fous ça vient de
paraître chez bouquins vie philosophique
c'est une reddition c'est également chez
bouquins et puis est le numéro 4 de
votre revue front populaire merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose